when we analyzed how the position vector
changed we know that the velocity for
circular motion is given by the radius
times the rate that the angle is
changing and it points tangential to the
circle so let's draw a few
characteristic arrows to show that at
this point we'll draw these pictures
with D theta DT positive so the velocity
points like that it points like this
points like that and these are all the
velocity vectors at different times
notice that if we make consider the
special case in which the theta DT is a
constant in that instance the magnitude
of the velocity V is given by our
magnitude of D theta DT and that is also
a constant but the velocity vector is
changing direction and we know by
definition that the acceleration is the
derivative of velocity and so what we
see here is where we have a vector
that's constant in magnitude but
changing direction and we now want to
calculate the derivative in this special
case we refer to this case as uniform
circular motion so this special case is
often called uniform circular motion
okay how do we calculate the derivative
of the velocity well recall that the
velocity vector R D theta DT those are
all constants because it's in the theta
hat direction
once again we'll decomposed theta hat
into its Cartesian components you see it
has a - I hat component and a plus J hat
component the I hat component is
opposite the angle so we have minus sine
theta of T I have plus cosine theta of T
J hat so when I differentiate the
velocity in time
this piece is constant so I'm only again
apply
the chain rule to these two functions so
I have our d theta/dt and i
differentiate sine i get cosine with the
minus sign so i have minus cosine theta
I'll keep the function of T just so that
you can see that D theta DT I had over
here the derivative of cosine is minus
sine D theta DT that's the chain rule
sine of theta DT D theta DT J hat and
now I have this common D theta DT term
and I can pull it out and I'll square it
now whether D theta DT is positive or
negative the square is always positive
so this quantity is always positive and
inside I have I'm also going to pull the
minus sign out and I have cosine theta
of T I have 2 sine theta of T J hat now
what we have here is the unit vector R
hat t our hat has a cosine adjacent in
the I hat direction and a sine component
in the J hat direction so our
acceleration
you